you actually work at being the best you
train at it don't you it's a choice ok
what do you take life by the what
whether what did I say and it's really
Who am I competed against you know me
the what the best d everyone do you ever
do you ever try to compete with the
drinking in the back house that you do
in the main house yeah often ok we're
talking metaphorical breaking you talk
about drinking in life who told my
drinking and alcohol you talk about
drinking water talking I'm talking about
the time you you called me and asked to
borrow five thousand dollars did I care
shed check you could have tried to cash
it there was nothing in thank you right
are you okay I'm fine he's just very
intense today today hey I don't let you
know that uh I'm on camera now so I know
you knew me when I was in I've known
your bond camera on on off yeah this is
actually proof there's a there's a
camera here so all right that's good
just want to let you know I'm I moved up
are you trying to lord that over me no
no no no I'm not trying to lure it over
i'm just saying take down a very heavy
you know what without suffering there's
no growth oh yeah oh god why are you
doing this again i'm blanking for more
awesome videos that teach you how to be
a man subscribe to our youtube channel
and follow us on twitter